[Music]
foreign
was killed on 11th of May on this to
create a very precise forensic analysis
of all circumstances of the shooting
how thorough it is is that we are
creating for the first time a spatial
reconstruction and Analysis through
footage and a photographic documentation
of the site that transforms the site
into a model that can be measurable to
the millimeter with that with the
unprecedented or unseen before footage
we can locate the precise position of
the journalists including Shirin
throughout the incident of the shooting
at them as well as the position for the
first time to precisely tell you exactly
where the Israeli occupation forces were
and where they shot out of we actually
know the hole that they shot out of
[Music]
thank you
family shouldn't have to wait another
day for justice that's why in addition
to con continuing our call for a U.S
investigation we are also calling on the
international criminal court board to
begin the process for holding the
killers accountable
foreign
[Music]
occupation forces shot shooting and we
have very strong evidence to say that
they deliberately targeted them
repeatedly as journalists
[Music]